[Applaudissements]
l'eco-trail c'est un événement qui a été
créée en 2008 par départ des amoureux de
courses nature et qui ont décidé
justement de créer un trade en région
parisienne et des courses nature aussi
avec avec plusieurs plusieurs
fondamentaux
c'était s'était mis justement dans l'adn
de l'événement de vouloir faire
découvrir le patrimoine culturel et
historique de la région ile de france
c'était le le terrain de jeu des
fondateurs d'aussi de sensibiliser à
toute la partie éco-responsabilité qui
n'est pas forcément de conscience
commune en 2000 en 2008 qui maintenant
fondamental on va dire pour pour tout le
monde et puis aussi de favoriser la
pratique du sport pour l'ensemble des
franciliens
donc ça n'existait pas forcément le
trade à cette époque là donc voila
c'était un vrai lancement en 2008 et
puis maintenant on a on a plusieurs en a
plusieurs épreuves en a cinq épreuves de
trade mais qui vont du 10e 80 km et deux
épreuves de marche nordique de 17 18 km
c'est un parcours nature on assure le 80
km à peu près 90% du parcours qui se
fait dans l'est dans les forêts avec une
toute toute petite partie bitumée sûr
sûr sûr l'arrivée le 80 km lui va partir
de l'île des loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines et va arriver au premier étage
de la tour eiffel juste avant ça avance
et 80 km le parc on va passer par part
donc il de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines ça va passer ensuite par
montigny but qu'au niveau du ch doit du
château et puis après emprunté toutes
les forêts domaniales de l'ouest
c'est pour tous types de coureurs
justement c'était la volonté la volonté
initiale c'était c'était de créer de
créer un événement on pouvait rassembler
le maximum de personnes possible des
sportifs aguerris comme des amateurs sur
sur l'éco trail aujourd'hui on à peu
près de 40% de néophytes donc des
personnes qui n'ont soit jamais qu ils
soient jamais participé à un treuil donc
on rend compte de l'universalité
justement un petit peu de cet événement
on a des personnes qui viennent courir
un 10 km en une heure et demie deux
heures qui viennent découvrir la
pratique on l'a découvert qu'ils
viennent courir 1 80 km en 5 heures et
demie parce que c'était parce que ces
deux sportifs aguerris